how are you both doing
how are you it's going pretty good for
people that have i like throwing a
curveball at the beginning
for people that have never seen anything
that you've ever done what's the first
thing you want them watching and why
fail fast
uh
yeah
i mean
well i mean he's got a much more
extensive cv so go on
i'm gonna say this because this is
um
this just you know means so much to
me to us to can it's it's it's you know
it was such a
um
we all were feeling it from very you
know deep down from day one from reading
the script to sitting here now to
whatever this journey is we've
it's been packed full of you know heart
for us so
um you know
it means so much just so i guess people
are gonna i'm gonna say
well fast also
uh at what point when you were reading
the script on what page did you realize
i will pay to be in this movie
you did pay to be in it i did i'm gonna
be paying that off for quite a long time
um
i i think really early on i don't know
exactly what page but
page seven
okay
but it's i mean i think even before i
got the script when i was told it was a
project that ken branagh had written and
he was going to direct and judy dench
kiron hines
oh and jamie jordan um
i i would have said yes anyway but
ken is not only an incredible actor and
director he's such a beautiful writer
and there was so much
heart in this script and the way it was
written was so beautiful that you know i
i
i was going to be a firm yes no matter
what if if it was coming from them if
they said yes then i was also going to
say yesterday yeah for me too you know i
um
i was
got a text and
from agents saying like ken brown i want
you to do this movie belfast how quickly
could you read it and i said well i
could read it tonight camera yeah a
movie called yes i'll read it tonight
job whatever plans i had i think i read
it very quick knew instantly i wanted to
do it spoke to ken the next day and that
we were we're after the races then i
think result was very quick the whole
thing so
yeah it was easy easy decision
for both of you um you're both obviously
um from the area this is obviously i'm
sure very personal to both of you did
you find yourself like sort of
maybe giving yourself more like more
pressure on yourself in this role than
maybe some of the others just because of
your own personal history with the
material
um i don't know it's hard one i don't
think so no i i felt like it was a real
like opportunity to tell like a
different story from
the north of ireland and from belfast
and and uh for people to see it through
a different lens and
um i've been lucky in my career i've
played characters from belfast before
and things often they weren't even meant
to be from buffalos but they changed the
script for me
um which being unfortunate
but never um so precisely is this
um
and i sort of felt very
uh honored to be able to do that and be
in a position to do that and you know i
guess
we felt so
uh wanted i think from an early point
like by ken you know that we
we were the people he wanted to portray
the
to the most important people ever in his
life so um
you know and actually what that did was
just made us all sort of excited and
very ready to to tell it and leave all
inhibitions and fear behind really up
certainly after day one you know ken
just
had this amazing way of just settling
everyone's very settled safe fun set you
know stemmed from him yeah
um
yeah i mean i think you know i think
before getting there uh doing sort of
research or you know i don't know if
research is the right word but you know
i ended up
falling down these rabbit holes on on
youtube just watching interviews of
women from belfast from that specific
time
to a little bit later and and
you know i don't know if it was pressure
necessarily but
you know having grown up with what
happened you know in the la 30 years
afterwards um 30 40 years afterwards you
kind of
it's just a responsibility you feel to
sort of tell these people's story in a
pure way and in a
in a
i don't know in a way that sort of
honors the struggles that they've all
been through but again as ken as jamie
said the minute we got to set
all of that kind of disappeared i mean
i'm sure it was in there somewhere but
it was just
it just felt
easy in a weird way and that's due to
ken
um i love learning about like how actors
work behind the scenes so for both of
you if you it doesn't have to be for
belfast it could be for anything but if
you have like a really tough scene on
like a monday maybe something really
dramatic maybe something really
emotional how early on are you actually
preparing for a day like that uh like
can you sort of take me through the way
you prepare
i always have when i go through a
schedule like schedules are always
subject to change
but i always
will like ear mark or like circle
like whatever day i'm most scared of if
i have like a day where it's i've had
like a 17 page dialogue scene or
something where i just know
beyond the emotion of it just the actual
physicality or you know having to learn
that's a substance i've seen having to
learn all those lines and i'll just and
i'll just get more and more stressed
down to that day he comes i always
yeah well i need i can't do it needs to
be printed out i have to have my
schedule printed and there'll be this
big red mark around
maybe maybe you shouldn't do a big red
mark and it might not be so scary
i don't know i mean
for me obviously a lot of my work is on
tv or has been to this point so
the the time that you have is just you
know your
stuff coming at you fast and furious so
i always sort of do
the weekend before is just the prep for
that week but you know the beauty of of
when you start a film is that you have
that script and it's set and it's done
and you're going to have seven weeks to
do it it just it's such a luxury because
your page count that you're doing every
day is so small so
i think you know the the sort of bigger
scenes that i had for this or or
whenever you have uh big scenes in other
films you sort of do a little bit of
prep before you go in and then it's i
don't you know i think it's the weekend
before you sort of do your work and then
the night before so that it's it's not
it's not too that's where it's dull
yeah it's not too overly
rehearsed or overly thought about
because you want to keep it spontaneous
as well
on that note i gotta go uh
congratulations on the movie i wish you
guys nothing but the best and i know
people are gonna you know what i mean
thank you so much thank you so much